is it better to be a black person or a
white person in 2022 why but I love
being black exactly like in society it's
better to be a white person what makes
you say that just the hierarchy in jobs
and everything like that if you do like
certain careers in University you're
more likely to excel than if you're a
bit of a black person but I I also love
him but I wouldn't change it either I'm
thinking more systematic system so I'm
fresh right so this is about it's quite
impressed you know it's racism right
like as in you can get a job I could be
a lawyer I could be a doctor but getting
higher in your position really counts on
the color of your skin let's be real
yeah and and not not only cultural as
your skills too but mostly they are
going to look at the color of your skin
and if you do get into higher position
most of the time you are a token you
know I I work in violence we're drunk so
forgive us there's no right or wrong
answer right we're just having
conversations but you know I work in
finance and you know I'm doing decently
for myself at the moment right now
there's no programs that help white
people get jobs like maybe white women
yeah so don't you think because that's
because I feel like that a part of that
is because they need to push it to show
that we're not racist and I don't know
if I'm a conspiracist or whatever you
want to call it like I do understand
they're like oh black women in power
like there was even like I think a
Barclays it was a bank I can't remember
which bank it was but there was a bank
that was helping women start business
and my brother sent it to me and I
remember it's like it's just like oh
black women in higher education but I
feel like a part of that is just to make
sure that the bank shows or like the the
government shows oh we're not racist by
the way like we do support black women
but unfortunately if you look at the
statistics black black people or people
of color are unfortunately poorer like
this is really scary because this is
what we were saying that um you know
black people probably statistically the
the people at the bottom tend to be
white so if you go to the Northern parts
of the country they tend to be the poor
areas and those 10 people dominantly
white I think like they are trying that
in the sense of all the programs helping
black people
um start like getting into their careers
and things like that but additionally I
think it's long overdue I think that
this should have been started a long
time ago so what do you mean by a song
overdue like um we're in 2022 like they
should have been helping black black
people
um
do you think quotas are racist like
programs like specifically for like
black people are racist because it's
basically saying like you can't do this
on your own we need to give you a
special program
but because of institutionalization
because of institutionalized racism it's
harder for us to do things on our own
like we will go to a job and there'll be
let's say five black people and five
black people I feel that it's a higher
chance of
foreigns do enable us to further our
careers but I feel like wait as my
friend said we are in 2022 so I feel
like um this should have been done
overdue so I understand what you're
saying however when you look at
universities that tend to do these sorts
of things so if you go to Yale or the
top universities in America where they
have affirmative action a lot of the
black students that get through um get
through to the university because of
affirmative action tend to do very badly
because they thought I would adapt
because obviously those are the top one
percent of people in in that country
that are allowed in that University and
in comparison the top 10 of black people
are in there might not be doing as well
basically teaching black kids to feel
stupid because they could be so smart
but they're at the wrong school can I
just say quickly like if a black person
gets them to yell
or anything like that they are a very
small minority of the University they
don't have people who are around them
that looks like them that acts like them
that are able to further them in their
career they feel like they're out of
place so that sets them down
automatically I feel like yeah also
because in general out of the population
there's less black people so of course
you'll see less black people at those
institutions institutions
education I just feel like black people
are already like that's a whole new
level already at a lower amount or red
in the University as a whole and when
you look at in a university as a whole
it needs higher education when you look
at black people and white people are
already at a lower minority in the
beginning so when you as a black person
as we walk into a university and we see
less of our people we're gonna feel shy
we're gonna feel unable to come forward
and really voice up and that's and and
probably that's why why most of the
universities now have ACS because tell
me what distinguished group you have for
white people you don't but then you
don't expect to say like hey you're
included but don't you think that if
there was a group for specifically for
white people you'd be calling it racist
no no you might not you might not but a
lot of people would okay yeah that's
right
[Music]
so why is it not racist where is the
black music but the biggest thing is the
thing is
but the thing is
that kind of we need it I get what
you're saying I get what you're saying
because we're excluded okay without it
walk into a club at Uni and it's no
offense
and we'll just be in the corner they
won't mix it up for us I understand what
you're saying I understand I went to
Russell Creek
units that means it's a top 20
University in top 20 universities you
don't tend to get many black people
it tends to be predominantly white right
hence why he had an instance music
probably yeah yeah it was always reading
one in room two yeah yeah and so without
a doubt the black people that go there
tend to make the ACs themselves yeah
because we need it because they don't
feel included in the general Society why
people don't really need that one
because
that's what I'm saying you're a minority
so of course you want to be around the
people who like you so you make those
groups don't see it as we walk why can't
you improve us all together why can't
the owners
to music do they have to
they don't personally have to enough
like so it's absolutely anything we all
have free will I'm Nigerian I'm Nigerian
if I had a Nigerian party I'm really
hungry sorry if I had a Nigerian party
today and there was five white people 30
black people would I try to make the
music be okay for the for the white
people I feel like you're more likely to
try and meditation yeah stop lying
you wouldn't let's be real let's be
honest you're not going to change the
music
but we are a lot more than five and
that's the difference but again you can
try and say okay five and three I I
understand
black people 30 of the country we
wouldn't so if there's if there's 10
people in a room only three of them
meant to be black but do you know sorry
um just as you say five um 30 of the
people in this country are black there's
certain areas that have more white
people and they're selling every side
more black people certain educational
areas have mostly black people than
white people so why are those certain
areas having a lower minority of black
people going into going into more of the
higher education so like there's sorry
one second so there's certain areas with
loads of white people and they're all
going into higher education in certain
areas with a small amount of white
people a large amount of black people
and more of the white people are going
into higher education so why is that
regardless of if we're 30 of the Gen of
the relationships why why do Indian
Americans dominate an education even
though they have dark skin and they're a
minority personally this might be this
might be wrong or they stay together and
it's there's a family close together I
feel like us black people we need to
come together more I mean sometimes we
go against each other I'm so sorry if
someone was like oh like it's already
war and not even like literally
intentional as in terms of like I'm
gonna beef them I'm gonna fight them I'm
gonna argue with them it's literally
like you just kind of deep down know
that like we we segregate which between
liar and darker skin it's even exactly
the white people segregate between like
like but the Asian there is a lot of
colorism in the Asia no because that's
because
that's because of um um colonization